i want to play a few clips for you today
of a monstrous donald trump being
interviewed by the christian
broadcasting network and declaring
himself a christian savior
this is really a wild god complex that
donald trump has it's like a jesus
complex i guess you would say
uh let's start with this first clip
where trump claims no one ever
has done more for christianity and for
all religions
than trump himself
you know nobody has done more for
christianity nobody has done more for
religion of all type than me
and they're really
doing things now too and i've always
said it they are against organized
religion
they're against
christianity and of course no we're not
what we are against is civil law based
on christian doctrine
we're against enmeshing church and state
we're against
discrimination against non-christians or
simply non-believers remember
non-religious
is protected and the absence of religion
is equally protected but trump with a
real god complex now i do want to say
i don't think trump is the person who's
done the most for
christianity and all religions as he
claims but
if indeed the leaked supreme court
decision holds and i believe it will we
know it's an accurate draft but it's a
draft from february if it holds in a few
weeks when it's released and roe v wade
is overturned
trump will be responsible for one of the
major accomplishments i would call it a
major coup but that term now we you've
got to be careful with that term we want
to be clear about what we mean
it would be one of the major
accomplishments of the retrograde
religious conservative movement
overturning roe v wade after four four
decades
uh really pieces of five decades
actually actually no it's just five
decades i don't even have to hedge uh
would be an absolute major
accomplishment and uh trump is
responsible for that he's the guy who
appointed the justices that made it
possible let's go to the next clip here
is donald trump
uh sort of uh now
on the on the heels of uh what was it jp
jd mandel no jd vance winning his
primary on tuesday night and j.r
majewski winning his primary on tuesday
night trump feels emboldened about the
power of his endorsement and he's
telling everybody else
i don't endorse you it's very bad i
remember joe biden saying months ago at
this press conference he had that he
goes you couldn't believe all these
republicans still afraid of trump is
like oh they're all afraid of trump
should republicans be afraid of you the
ones that are are not in line with you
and your views well if they want to win
politically probably because if i
endorse them they win and if i don't
endorse them they don't win i mean
that's almost 100 of the case now it's
really more like 57 of the case and i
think it's really important to remember
that although trump did get two
victories so far this primary uh season
and he may get more there's no question
trump may get more trump's record on
endorsements is pretty pretty shoddy
it's kind of like swiss cheese first of
all he endorsed a lot of uh presumptive
front-runners and incumbents and there's
a major incumbency bias in american
politics and even given all that his
record is not that great like it's
hovering right around and slightly below
60 percent so it's not actually true
that uh everybody trump touches turns to
gold but
it may end up being true in 2022 remains
to be seen one last clip here here's
trump talking about disney of course
disney now under fire for opposing
florida's don't say gay bill and people
are protesting at disney and they want
to cancel mickey and minnie and all
these different things anyway trump says
walt disney wouldn't be happy with
what's going on i think what's happened
with disney and what disney's doing walt
disney is looking down what's he
thinking he's not happy okay
walt disney said what happened to my
beautiful magic kingdom uh he's not
happy
no it's uh
it's a terrible thing so anyway
there's trump uh speculating on how walt
disney would feel about the magic
kingdom today
based on disney's opposition to the
don't say gay bill they get the don't
say gay bill is of course disgusting and
uh i hate theme parks and have no
interest in ever going to disney again
but uh i like disney's taking a position
on this and by the way disney wouldn't
take a position on this i don't think
if they didn't calculate that it's
probably an okay pr move to take the
position that they did opposing the
don't say gay bill a very strange
interview with donald trump but an
emboldened donald trump on the heels of
some primary endorsement successes we'll
have these video clips for you if you're
just listening to the podcast today or
maybe listening on the radio we'll have
these video clips on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video